you know i had decided i was gonna quit
youtube about two years ago i just
wasn't sure how to go about it but in my
mind i was so sad on it then i started
looking back on why i started youtube uh
or when i started you know i was in
sweden i was living in a all alone i was
technically on a good track you know i
was in university i had my career path
laid in front of me i knew
even though i wasn't feeling good i knew
i would be fine but i remember how stuck
i felt at that time just doing something
i didn't want to do whatsoever so i was
just doing youtube hoping
praying
because it wasn't even a job back then
really for gaming channels at least but
maybe it would work out and just
remembering how stuck i felt back then
to now where i just feel so free i i
just wanted to really say thank you for
that um for making that possible
there's been a lot of changes on the
channel lately so i figured it made
sense to do kind of an update video on
looking on the past and and where the
channel is now and where it's going in
the future as you know
which i've kind of shoved in your face
uh me and mars i moved to japan and i
feel like you know on the topic of
quitting now would really be the perfect
time you know my channel kind of peaked
we tried so many different things done
so many different things and i just
yeah
it'd be the perfect that you know we
moved to japan and so they lived happily
ever after
it's funny because i even see comments
kind of like begging me to quit like bro
just quit already
what else do you want
and i get it it just it makes sense
right but the awkward part is
i'm still here
post credit
hey guys
i'm not quitting
but yeah two years ago when i decided i
was gonna quit it was because i had gone
through so much drama at the time and
you know i hasn't always been perfect
but i do feel like i've gone through a
lot of scrutiny as well and the negative
would just outweigh the good at that
point but it didn't feel right to quit
just because other people especially
when so many people were are still being
so supportive you know and yeah i look
back on my 10 years on youtube and it's
been a wild [ __ ] ride and i would do
it all again in a heartbeat i'm so
grateful for all the memories and
experience that i had so far but the
thing is i don't want to do it again
because i'm a different person now
because of it i look back on everything
that we've done and i'm super proud of
it and and it's amazing but you know
i'm ready for new experiences and
different things i think i realized at
that time that you know keep trying to
push the channel to grow more and more
and more all the time wasn't doing
anything for me personally i wasn't
getting anything out of the money or the
recognition or the fame at least that
part had kind of peaked you know what am
i gonna do with more i don't know i felt
like i was growing the channel just
because
it's expected of you to do so you guys
have to keep pushing your youtube
channel keep growing keep seeing those
numbers go up you know because that's
what's expected of you but just realize
like why when why
i think if i realized that if i had 100
less of subscribers or whatever or
thousands less i'd still feel just as
accomplished and just as proud of myself
so
what's the point of keep always trying
to push it you know but i would always
just keep trying to grow the channel as
best as i can you know you the views are
there and everyone wants wants them to
go up and uh i would stress out over
every single upload i got into really
bad habits i got out of them anyway but
you know i just realized i was so
addicted to youtube at that point and it
was all i really cared about uh it
really took up all my focus and energy
for such a long time really and
that's what made me successful but i
didn't necessarily feel more successful
because of it i guess is my point i i
know this sounds kind of like i'm
complaining i'm just reflecting really
so two years ago i said i was gonna
retire and that confused a lot of people
because i still uploaded videos but the
thing is
uh what i meant was i just want to do
youtube the way i did it when i started
which was for fun it
believe it or not i didn't do it to
become this i don't know big channel or
big character
um and so instead i try to just focus on
yeah what was fun about youtube which is
really at its core just to share stuff
with you guys
and uh
i've been avoiding all the drama been a
good boy thank you
try to avoid all the [ __ ] and just
try to enjoy it the best i can not focus
too much on the results and youtube
actually started to become fun again for
for the past two years and that's when i
realized you know why should i quit it's
my dream after all to do youtube i've
worked so hard for this i think other
people could see it as oh he got fame he
got money you know what else does he
want but that's never the
that's at it at its core that's never
why i got into youtube and felt enjoyed
it so much to begin with so that's why
i'm still here i still enjoy sharing
stuff with you guys and uh i don't want
to just give all that up doing it for a
long time though
your channel goes through a lot of
changes i mean like i started doing call
of duty videos and then i went into
horror and then you know half wheels and
you know it's just constantly been
changing and i think when you do it for
such a long time it comes with the price
of you know letting some people down
because they prefer a certain type of
content and there's always going to be
expectations and people having different
preferences which i understand obviously
but it also makes it feel like you're
always letting someone down and like
whatever you're doing is never good
enough and i know a lot of people feel
very strongly about certain videos that
i did in the past should come back you
know view news or meme review or more
gaming but to me those things are just
not stuff i'm personally that into
anymore i mean sure i play still play
games and i'll always enjoy that and
there will always be that in the channel
but at the moment you know i don't have
that much time been spending my days
just enjoying japan really
but also looking back on a lot of my
content it just feels so lame doing
videos talking about drama that no one
gives a [ __ ] about a couple days later
uh doing videos about memes that changes
like every other day what's like what's
the point it all just feels like
distractions uh and i'm not saying now
my channel is so deep but it just feels
a bit
shallow to always upload that kind of
stuff i kind of feel the same way about
shorts to be honest they really just
feel like distractions and that's it i
don't want to sound preach or anything
and for the future i just want to keep
doing videos the way i have been doing
sort of this tempo at least my first
year in japan i really just want to
enjoy having fun here and and making the
most out of it and not stress about what
the next upload is going to be all the
time and that feels really really good i
have this bigger thing i filmed for
example but i
i'm going surfing after this and i'm you
know making choices like that
sorry
it will just be a little longer so yeah
i just i really appreciate you guys
sticking through all the changes and i
still do try my best but i really really
appreciate all the understanding and
support is it time
yeah why not
some things never change